550.
hey guys it's max yes i did order the
airpods max
no i am not happy about it and
my only question is how much are the
airpods
pro max gonna cost whenever they come
out with those if these are 550 bucks
today we're going to talk about these
new headphones what killer features they
have
that make them commend this price we'll
also cover how they stack up against
their biggest competitors at least based
off specs
we're gonna do a head-to-head comparison
early next week so if you want to see
that
first off let me know what you want me
to compare them to and second click that
subscribe button below so you guys don't
miss out on that video
and with that you guys can help us reach
our goal of 600 000 subscribers before
march
which is our two year mark officially
running this channel
on youtube with that let's jump in and i
have to say
that i love the look it looks very
simple and classy
we have some mesh up top which looks
like a homepod
and then we have what seems to be an
apple watch
tilted on its side with a little pad
attached to it which looks
interesting the headband opens up
smoothly so there's not little notches
or anything like that
knowing apple is going to have a nice
tension system so it's going to stay
exactly how you want it and that's nice
to have a perfect fit there
the over the ear cushions attach
magnetically so this should be very easy
to take off and put on
but they're also gonna stay there once
you attach them and they are really
large as you guys could see
it's gonna go over your ears and this is
my favorite kind of design
because you can wear it for a long time
without getting pressure
on your ears now i have the sony xm3s
and they are good but after about two
hours
they start hurting my head apple's
saying the fit
is gonna be awesome and they're gonna be
super comfortable
and i think that's probably gonna be
true based on the headband which looks
like it's very lightweight
and then of course we have a bunch of
aluminum what i'm curious about
is the weight we'll take a look at that
in just a second and it's very
interesting that there is no logo on the
actual cups we see
so many headphones with massive logos on
there they want people to know what
brand it is
here apple is just going for a very
classy clean look
with that said on the inside they did
put a little bit of fanciness
in there this ear cup looks awesome and
that homepod like
mesh actually changes and it gives you
the left and right
indication on the inside and with that
your apple watch pods have that crown
now of course i'm excited to hear the
sound quality from these things i know
they have to be good
but what i might be even more excited
for is using this digital crown
i love it on the apple watch you have
the haptic feedback
adjusting the volume of certain things
when i'm using my apple watch as a
remote is so sweet you just dial it in
and i think this might be the ultimate
way to control
your headphones you know some headphones
have different buttons that you have to
click
and tap some have touch surface that you
have to swipe your hands and then it
kind of works sometimes and it doesn't
this is going to feel awesome and not
only can you scroll it to be able to
adjust your volume
you could tap on it multiple times to
skip songs or invoke siri
let me know below what you guys think
about this control method now i'm also
surprised
that they have five different color
options i thought with the pro device
they might give us
two maybe or maybe even one but they're
going all
out and with the regular air pods you
don't really have a color option you
have one
but with these ones apple's happy to
give you some color options
as long as you cough up some serious
dough
and now let's talk about the good stuff
the audio quality
apple says it sounds like an epiphany i
am sure it's going to sound fantastic
i've been blown away by
every apple product as far as sound
quality the homepods
sound shockingly good with rich deep
bass that no other speaker that size can
put out
the homepod mini smokes the other
speakers in that size and even just the
price range as far as sound quality
i have no doubt that these are going to
sound super good but the question is
are they going to sound twice as good as
the other alternatives that are already
fantastic on the market
apple is using six microphones on the
outsides to detect
noise and then two microphones on the
insides just like
on the airpod pros to listen to what
you're hearing
and adjust the sound i don't know how
many times a second
to be able to fine tune it so there's no
distortion and it sounds fantastic
no matter what you're listening to now
with that they have beam forming
microphones and i have no doubt that the
call quality is going to be phenomenal
from these headphones on the inside we
have these large
drivers the apple design themselves and
they are saying that
you're gonna hear previously unheard of
texture and accuracy i want to test that
for myself
the drivers themselves have dual magnets
to minimize distortion across the whole
range to give you
very good clear playback even maxed out
which is how i like to use my headphones
and the key to that is computational
audio now we know that with iphones and
other smartphones
computational photography is what makes
the photos
so amazing not the hardware here of
course we have great hardware
but with that apple put an h1 chip
in each cup and each one of those h1
chips have 10
audio cores that are going to be
listening to
the sound on the outsides it's going to
be listening to the microphones insides
to dynamically adjust the audio
and that's what's going to make these
sound fantastic
now we also have a single button across
from
the digital crown and that's for your
active noise cancellation
you can press it down once to go into
transparency mode
and based off the airpod pros that
transparency mode is going to be
fantastic these have the best
transparency mode i have ever heard
from any device that i have tested and
because these are airpods and we have
the computational audio
you are going to get spatial audio if
you guys have not experienced this it is
wild you're watching a movie you have
your airpods in
you're turning your head you see the
source of the sound it's all around you
but you're really kind of immersed in it
almost like you're there in the scene it
is
crazy you guys have to check it out and
of course because these are air pods
they're gonna have all the other
convenience features
so as soon as you open them up you're
gonna have a little pop-up on your phone
you hit connect
they are instantly set up and not only
on your iphone but they're gonna be set
up with all of your other devices with
your macs with
whatever else you have and then you can
easily switch between them so as soon as
you pick up an ipad
bam they're connected and one of my
favorite features
is announce messages it sounds kind of
weird but i love it when i have my
earpods in i'm doing something all
sudden i get a text message siri reads
that out loud to me i can respond
once you get used to that it's very
convenient and then always on
siri that is also convenient at first i
never wanted to use it i thought it was
kind of gimmicky but once you get used
to it you train yourself to use it it is
convenient
and then of course the feature where you
just pull them off of your head they
instantly pause your music
you put them back on it gets unpaused
those simple things
is what makes the regular airpods and
the airpod pros
just so nice to use and even people that
don't have apple devices
buy them and use them now not everything
is sunshine and rainbows
one thing that i want to complain about
is this case
what is this thing i mean i'm guessing
it's probably magnetically
attached to the little flap there so it
should be pretty easy to put it in you
don't have to deal with the zipper
but man the headband is exposed you have
some of the aluminum that
is exposed the crown is right there i
know they're going to shut off as soon
as you put them in
it's just weird i wish we had something
that had a little bit more protection
that looked a little bit more standard
and maybe the ear cups could fold in
this this lays flat but still i'd feel
weird just tossing it into
a backpack and we know when these things
after you include taxes there were 600
bucks
to order them but who knows maybe
apple's going to sell that separately
it's going to be like a 100 pro case or
something now i could be wrong but the
biggest competitors that come to my mind
are the sony xm4s
and the bose 700s if there's other ones
that match it better
let me know down below now these are the
best of the best when it comes to
active noise cancellation and they're
also very highly praised as far as sound
quality
but when it comes to the price the xm4s
are currently
280 bucks and the bose are now
340. so you guys see there's a massive
difference in price
so let's go ahead and compare the specs
now unfortunately apple doesn't give us
a lot of
information we have no specs for like
the frequency response or really
anything
else they just say that these have high
fidelity sound and it sounds like an
epiphany
so i guess we'll have to wait for that
but we can compare things such as the
weight
and wow they weigh 385
grams compared to 254 for the bose and
the sony's that's about 50 percent
more weight so i really hope the
headband and the ear cups are ultra
comfortable
we can compare the microphones the
airpods max have nine total microphones
compared to eight on the bose and five
on the sony's
but with the airpods eight of those are
for active noise cancellation
with the bose you have six for active
noise cancellation
but the bose use one more microphone for
a voice pickup during
calls compared to having three on the
airpods max
and all of them do have quick charge but
as far as the specs they don't line up
apple gives you an hour and a half for
five minutes the sony's actually give
you five
hours for just 10 minutes of charging so
that is better
and the bose if you charge for 15
minutes you'll get three and a half
hours so that seems like a little bit
worse than the other two now it does
look like apple is sticking
with lightning i was kind of expecting
usb type-c for such a high-end device
and then with the portless iphone rumors
that are coming out and them ditching
lightning
but nope they're sticking to that and in
typical apple fashion there is no
headphone jack
so just like the iphones the new ipads
and
i mean who knows maybe they'll get rid
of it on the mac soon
you can't just plug them in like you can
with the bose or the sony's now
you can still get a lightning to three
and a half millimeter audio cable
apple's charging 35 bucks for that so
you can't use it with your mac
you don't have to have bluetooth but you
do have to have them
charged in order to use them unlike some
of its competitors
now as far as battery life you guys saw
that the airpods max do have 20 hours of
battery life
but that is with active noise
cancellation or transparency mode
enabled
that uses a lot of computational audio
stuff going on
and apple doesn't give us any sort of
info
on how long they last if you have that
turned off i know the battery life is
going to be better there
now as far as the bose those are also 20
hours of battery life
but taking a look at the sony's those
are rated for 30 hours
with active noise cancellation turned on
or 38 hours
with it turned off so there you guys go
those are the new
airpods max honestly even though my name
is max i wish they didn't call it that i
wish they went with airpods studio it
sounds a lot more classy
and clean and high-end but i'm just
guessing that
they didn't want to go and compete with
the beats studio
so we have the airpods max and maybe i'm
right maybe next year we'll have a new
airpods pro max for a thousand dollars
or something insane
like that let me know what headphones i
should compare them with if there's
another higher end
option that is popular that sounds great
let me know in the comment section below
and let me know your thoughts overall on
these
is apple crazy for charging 550 bucks
it does seem weird because they have
some great devices that are low priced
like this new macbook
we have the 99 homepod mini and then we
have these crazy expensive
headphones i want to hear your guys's
opinions go ahead and click that circle
above
to subscribe and help us reach 600 000
before our official two-year mark here
on youtube that would be absolutely
amazing and you guys can see some other
great videos
right over there this has been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]